reject Nation got Transformers trailer
we are here today to check out rise of
the Beast John how are you I am I'm
feeling beastly how are you good I'm
sweaty from doing cargo came back here
throwing a flannel of Beanie to hide the
fact that I'm all sweaty and just came
back from doing cardio thing and now I
didn't bring any attention to it that's
how you get a job done ladies and
gentlemen leave a like let's get to it
[Music]
for millions of years
foreign
[Music]
ers
Basketball stand down I'm not the one to
fear Pride
the darkness coming
there are beast wars coming
look at those concept art from uh
another movie last night I think
Bumblebee
it was all a dream
whoever I'm not driving classic
[Applause]
whoa nicely done
Transformers killing cops
look how cool this looks
oh
damn it looks like the cartoons
your past
the Rhino future
you've never faced anything like this
that's a great life
not bad
that looks awesome nice
[Music]
RC looks sick all righty wow well that
looks really cool yeah so this movie
three nothing at the other day it's not
gonna be I mean I heard that the uh
Decepticons are gonna be factoring in in
some way because it's supposed to be
taking place I believe in like the mid
90s 94 or something like that that's
gonna be like a few years after
Bumblebee which I love we love did you
love them I love them I love them yeah I
quite enjoyed it I quite loved that
bumblebee movie this looks like a great
merger of both of them because it
doesn't quite look like the Michael Bay
movies and it doesn't quite look like
the Bumblebee movie either it looks like
it's going to be that great blend
because you know how a lot of people
really love that opening parts of the
first bumblebee movie that really felt
like the animated movie come to life and
it looks like they were capitalizing on
that bringing it here and now they're
going to be marrying the franchises into
it in a way you know but come on the
beasts look cool Optimus
primates Primal I think is what it's
called because we're supposed to have
the terracons we're just the main
villains in this one I believe the
Predacons and then maximals the Beast so
everything about it is looking really
cool of course the generation one
Optimus Prime looks really sick is that
Ron Perlman who's voicing the did they
have an official name I haven't looked
at the IMDb for it yet do they have an
official name for the gorilla one uh
Optimus Prime yeah remembers there's
gonna be like primate or Primal but I
guess it's gonna be Optimus primal but
yeah the action looks really sick and
then the trailer was reminding me of
like the Black Panther trailer the first
one and the cree trailer and then I'm
looking to see Stephen cable Junior yeah
the guy who did Creed too so I'm like
this makes sense yeah there's something
about the Rhythm to it that reminded me
of it I mean this looks like a really
sick trailer no yeah absolutely this
took like the best things I remember
about the first transfer the first
Michael Bay Transformers movie like
especially the position that Anthony
Ramos is in it looks like something kind
of similar to like a sandwich Wiki sort
of character but yeah with like an
ethnic but ethnic because that's what we
gotta do what's the one thing we haven't
done in transform we had a market here
we gotta have a Latino leading man
yeah he is and I hope there's a musical
number at least a few times throughout
this movie but yeah this this took what
I liked about that first Transformers
movie and then yeah crashed it into like
seeing that Crescendo at the end looking
like we might be building up to some
kind of cybertron-esque Ultimate
Showdown and finally taking the fight
away from Earth where the Transformers
and the Decepticons and terracons
everybody just loves to fight it out on
Earth but yeah this looks uh fun and
Punchy and the effects look great it
looks like they're using the best again
of the design approach as Michael Bay's
Transformers movies but you know
simplifying it just a little bit enough
that it kind of matches more with the
cartoon like I don't know this looks
like the best of a Transformers uh you
know live action movie that hopefully
you could hope for I feel like having a
little bit of that black panther Vibe a
little bit of that Espionage a little
bit of that world-rending Stakes but
then yeah this imagination and expanding
on you know getting the Beast Wars
basically Canon of characters in here
like that was the Transformers that I
had growing up sort of is like that was
the cartoon that was running that was
most Vivid in my life so that was kind
of bringing back Primal images to my
brain and I appreciated that very much I
heard the movie's gonna have like Heist
qualities to it it looks like it would
while this looks like there's a war and
all the same kind of big Stakes that
you're used to in a Transformers movie
it does have a heist kind of feeling to
it yeah well it feels suspenseful yeah I
can't believe how clear it is too like
like I said I feel like this really is
the the version of marrying the
Bumblebee and the Bumblebee movie and
the Michael Bay films because it doesn't
have that like
yellow machine yeah he has it looks like
he's really sweaty and sunny the best of
the base it's abilities and then you
went okay now keep the camera a little
more still so you can actually see some
of this stuff it looks clear and it
looks like the main characters are the
Transformers themselves and Anthony
Ramos is going to be a character to help
support that but it doesn't look like
it's about it because even you know
bumblebee was like really about Haley
steinfeld's character yeah and this
looks like it's about the Transformers I
don't know sometimes the trailers do
mislead you into that though they
absolutely do I think it's going to be
the transfers or the main character
especially with the finale like how you
were pointing out with going to this big
climactic one around I don't see any
humans here it's just Transformers and
they're just in Lego
and yeah it looks like a different
planet Earth it could be though I don't
know yeah you never know they'll do that
they're like we have to convince the
audience there are going to be Mass
casualties so I don't know they just
want to an abandoned Freight yard or
something what happens to these kids
though are they gonna they should do a
Cinematic Universe crossover where you
you get all them coming together
you have Haley Steinfeld Anthony Ramos
and Shia LaBeouf Megan Fox
who's married to Jason Statham Mark
Wahlberg's daughter and her Irish not
Irish boyfriend yeah this is part four
yeah yeah yeah oh mark
yeah man I'm an events are okay I'm
making Transformers but Optimus primal
looks like the [ __ ] I'm so excited for
that it's like a year for Apes I can't
wait well what did you think about this
trailer leave your thoughts down below
be sure to subscribe click that
notification Bell leave a like last but
not least let's send this with a
Michael B go subscribe to omnimedia's
channel he's got a YouTube reaction
coming out for Edge of Tomorrow and he's
probably hustling right now to get the
reaction out for this trailer so go
support him go watch him he's
collaborating with us on this channel
quite a bit lately so go do it let's go
now go to Omni media channel o m n as in
Nancy number one media om n is Nancy
number one media go there right now I
mean it go leave this video go go go go
go go go go Power Rangers
[Music]